welcome to this video playing
International Master Damian from Germany
have played him before of course it's a
it's a teammate of mine as I mentioned
can i play something funky here I
probably shouldn't okay so what can I do
him sort of you know his his repertoire
so I am unsure what to do okay so now we
transpose into a regular tirage okay
it's going for this g5 business which I
don't know well taking here I didn't
even know that this move is existing hmm
okay I thought that take on e5 but well
I'm obviously not a not an expert one
night b3 night b3 if he takes and goes
g4 I'm losing this pawn right I would
have compensation but hmm what do I play
Bishop c2 and give up the pawn in that
way no I don't know I'm not really sure
what why Bishop is doing in this
position so maybe I'm giving up the pawn
like that
yeah and Angie fall I mean does this
this almost has to be played grabbing
the pony yeah and he will grab so I
thought here should be six Bishop f4
that maybe maybe yes Queen f6 no is
playing differently okay so let's put
this here should to age six
is this too lame mmm I can also take the
pawn but he's got a five okay I'd like
to I'd like to play that I mean start
clear that he wants to castle at all but
it is an annoying move also stuff like
Knight f5 ninety-seven might be my
becoming yes but he's not threatening to
take so
I just want to have all pieces in play
and I mean okay I mean I would hate to
play this as Blackie quite obviously
as I don't want to get attacked but he's
a really good defender so let's let's
see what can I do here I cannot
sacrifice yet and one day a virgin
should just play ninety three and then
can I smash on if I if I he can he can
play Queenie seven but then I have night
before one night f-for actually right
therefore you might take place before I
don't know okay well let's do first
things first and now Knight f4 is strong
I'm pretty sure attacking d5 attacking
d5 Knight h5 and Knight takes bishop
takes this collapses only five long
castles are going to take both the rook
I think and this looks Wow
this I mean no this shouldn't be
defensible I have every every piece per
plant plate design yeah it's it's really
really not fun I mean this is the only
one I think I don't know what's better
this looks attractive here threatening
all kinds of discovered things and this
is this is probably the best which looks
terrible like this this the dark squares
are total catastrophe yeah this is sg5
line is very interesting but it is risky
I have lost with it many times with
black but without knowing things really
it is simply the case that while black
is often doing ok it is very tough to
play in blitz chess as you have this
this is bad King all the time and here I
don't know yeah white is already better
he according to the computer b6 the best
move and then Knight a 6 ok not even my
move but now I now I change the stack
and gives white a huge edge him again I
can take this is even stronger this is
even stronger forcing the thing and here
he could have defended with Bishop age 4
here the computer computer defense I
didn't see the move at all something
like that supposed to be equal okay I'm
definitely winning yeah this this this
line with g5 is very interesting as a
fighting fighting option but it's
something that it's very difficult to
play with no time on the clock and blitz
or quicker time controls
okay I hope you enjoyed this thanks for
watching